[Music]
[Applause]
just in time
matt barnes stephen jackson uh former
nba players
they were in the the association as the
kids like to say for a long time
and they have a podcast a very popular
podcast
called all the smoke they join us on the
program
uh let me start with who came up with
the idea to start the podcast
um me uh you know jack and i were both
respectively working
with um espn and fox at the time and
getting a lot of positive feedback
but you know working for those kind of
networks you got to kind of walk a
straight line and
you know jack and i can walk a straight
line but we'd rather step out every once
in a while
um so i told him let's try a podcast and
i didn't really know what it was at the
time i just knew we could freely speak
um he's like what is it i'm like i'm not
sure he's like but i'm in
and from there we're off running but
what's the goal
i think to create a platform we're able
to tell our own stories
um i think for so long other people have
told our stories and some people have
done a good job but some people
have put their spin on it and i think
for people
who have actually walked in our shoes uh
to be able to tell our own storage is
special especially in
this day and age sometimes you can get
that player to relax
that's the goal but sometimes
that person may not know they're kind of
walking into something that could get
him in trouble
well i think the good the good thing
about our platform is
we come off as we were emotions on our
sleeves
so they come in free and open because as
soon as you walk into our studio you see
me and matt being ourselves
you know the same people we are on and
off the camera so i think
i think we welcome for people to come in
and be and be their unfiltered self
because that's how we live our lives you
know we wear emotions on our sleeves so
you know this is a platform for people
to to to be
their their real selves and not the
person that everybody expect them to be
being on tv or being an athlete did you
ever interview anybody that
you didn't like when you started the
interview
but liked them after the interview i
wouldn't say
didn't like i would probably just say
didn't know as well
or even something we were actually just
talking about the other day even people
we think we know well
when we actually sit down and interview
we learn so much more but i'll say one
person that
um i was pleasantly surprised with and
didn't really
understand his impact in the space was
jim gray
and his imprint um in this space over
you know
however long he's been doing it i think
30 40 plus years
um to just to kind of understand you
know having ali's first and last
interview and everyone in between
um i love that like he was one of our
favorite interviews and he was so
you know what when his name came up i'm
like jim j jim gray the interview
yeah okay we could definitely do jim
gray but i just had a whole new found
appreciation for him
um once we are done talking because i
mean his his i mean his
the the the trail he set is you know
going to go down in history as one of
the greatest to ever do it
i call him the forest gump of uh sports
broadcasters because
he's been everywhere like you bring up a
name and
the jim gray was there it's like you
know elvis at the white house and
uh you know jim gray was there so you
know
he's he's interviewed everybody yeah
he's special
who came up with the title all the smoke
um we put a name we we we opened it up
to our
our fans to kind of think of a name and
then oddly enough my sister came up with
the name
so i told i don't remember i think i was
going to offer someone like 2500 if they
can come up with the name
but since my family never came up with
the name i just kind of charged it to
the game so i just gave her a hug and
said thank you
[Laughter]
but all the smoke is not what we think
all the smoke is
correct i think literally and phys i
mean some
some some days we're blowing it down in
here i'm not gonna lie to you dan and
it's
you could barely see i could barely see
my counterpart uh but from for the most
part i think all the smoke has several
different meanings and i just think you
know
it's kind of an unfiltered view of
information we're bringing you you know
so we're we're bringing you a lot of
smoke all the smoke however you want to
say it so
i guess there's a couple different uh
meanings for it but you know we cover
each of them
stephen are you better high when you're
interviewing
uh dan i'm never not high yeah okay
even now even now even though even now
really wait wake and bake you can wake
and eat you can wake and eat your
edibles we wake and bake is it good to
get you early in the day or later in the
day
it doesn't matter because at the end of
the day uh this is this is nothing new
to us
and um we don't do things for
for people or to be positive or to be
popular
you know these these are the things that
we've been doing our whole career
to keep us active to keep us sane to be
able to make it through
you know the ups and downs of life and
this is has worked for us this is
this is what they say if it ain't broke
don't fix it and uh
you know it works for me let me add to
that though dan i would say it's better
to get jack
early because i i've i've caught him if
we have three interviews sometimes i
have to elbow him sometimes i catch him
nodding off mid-interview so
i would say get jack earlier than later
it's called
all the smoke with matt barnes and
stephen jackson uh
what's the first question you would ask
paul pierce if you had him on
we've had him yeah we had paul already
well not lately
yeah i mean i'm gonna be honest with you
i wouldn't ask him nothing because he's
not doing nothing that nobody don't do
i think i think just the fact that it
was on camera that and
and and people you know wanna wanna
judge him for it but
that's done everywhere it's just all
athletes do it it's just not on camera
so
for people to just judge him for having
fun and having a good time
yeah shouldn't have been on camera yeah
you got to be more private what you do
when you're representing the
uh uh uh uh what i'm looking for a
company
a company like espn but at the same time
all players do it
and disney but that's what you see
people that work at disney do it they're
just not on camera
well i think that kind of goes back to
what i said earlier um dan you know
about you know jack and i being able to
walk that straight line but sometimes
we'd like to step
off that line and you know we've done
everything pretty much you saw in paul's
video we've just
it hasn't been on camera you know what i
mean and we don't want to speak for
other people but we know other people do
it too
i just think it was a combination of all
of it on camera
and it being disney you know it was a
little hard so i was actually surprised
you know i had spoke to someone who
worked at espn that night you know i was
like yo is paul going to be okay and you
know the person's like you know they
don't like what he did but you know i'm
not
sure if there's much they can do and
then you know a day later he's fired so
uh it's very unfortunate you know we're
big fans of paul and we know he'll land
on his feet but
you just got to kind of be careful this
day and age i guess what's the biggest
tab you guys put up at a
club oh
i like 20 20 000. 20 000. but see what
you got to realize though when we when
we go to clubs the teams i've been on
the team
we've been on we all go out as a team so
that 20 000 has been broke down between
10 millionaires so it's really not that
much money we always together we had a
situation in new york not too long ago
where we got the company card and did a
little bit of damage on it
just just myself and jack and a couple
people
buying everyone shots in the restaurant
how much
how much matter yeah what was it i don't
know i don't know if you want to say it
out loud because
by five brian's right here okay 5k yeah
a dinner or dinner for two or dinner for
three ended up costing five thousand
that night so we had a little bit of fun
what's the one question you would want
to ask michael jordan
oh man oh man
uh i think i would want to ask him to
come on our show
this is a good one i like that that was
good um
you are high steven no that's not a good
question you want to that's a great
question
i need the second question then i think
uh
nothing's more important him coming on
our show right now first and foremost
first and foremost sorry
i would like to ask him um you know i've
seen him he's kind of opened up a little
bit more
um in the last maybe two
three four years and i think really
since kobe's passing
um his speech at the funeral was was
incredible
and and what he brought to that moment
was incredible
and just kind of ask him you know is
seeing kobe do it
being more open being one of more open
superstars does that encourage him
to do it a little more because he's
someone we've always kind of wanted to
know
what is like behind the scenes i think
his his uh his uh
his doc last dance i think the last
dance really led us into a side of mike
we've never been able to see because you
know social media and cameras weren't
around back then
um and he's one of you know a lot of
people's favorite person favorite
players so i just
we like to kind of see a little bit more
behind the scenes obviously we want to
respect his privacy and he's not that
type of person we understand but
i think you know the last few years
we've been kind of seeing him open up
more and more and
we just like that to continue and it was
kind of interesting too that you and
kobe started out as
you know adversaries and then grew
closer because of one moment there
right right which i don't know how often
that happens but you know you have the
flinch and then all of a sudden
you know you guys eventually become very
good friends
yeah i mean that was a you know uh
copying myself
kind of started i met him in in 98 when
i went to ucla
you know him coming to la at 18 he was
young and he was at
around ucla all the time so you know
we'd see him he'd be playing pickup
games with us in the summer time he
would prac
he would work out in poly i would sneak
back in and watch him train so it kind
of just became like a wow
okay i'm gonna have to eventually guard
someone like this one day to eventually
make in the league and then
just respecting each other knowing every
time you know he we we played each other
i really looked forward to it and then
um
you know kind of came to a head in in
orlando in 2010 with the ball fake
and then after that season you know he
called me up in and literally said
you know anyone crazy enough to with me
is crazy enough to play with me do you
want to be a laker
and literally three days later i was a
laker you know so we went from
opponents to teammates to brothers
because we were both going through a lot
of stuff off the court that season so we
were bonding on and off the court you
know going to dinner hanging out
you know spending time together and i
got a chance to really know him as a
person not just the basketball player
you guys have had some great interviews
even even when you had calvin johnson on
that his nickname was butterfingers in
high school and crazy right
imagine that i know and then stephen
basically said
you know how do you get from
butterfingers to megatron
right yeah it's a hell of a
transformation it was it was great
yeah like but uh you know you had steve
nash
chris paul durant uh do you guys have
vizine as a sponsor i was wondering
about that
would that be something good that maybe
you should have a bad idea
that's a good idea you might you might
have just you might be honest something
there dan we
we're gonna have uh we're gonna have our
internal team hit them up
uh stephen if you were playing in your
free agent you had to pick the nets or
the lakers to play for
who would you play for nets the nets
yes because easy i'm good friends with
kyrie
um i'm more of a fan of kd than anybody
and uh kyrie than anybody i love lebron
i would love to play with him
it's hard to say not play with lebron
but i have a relationship with those
guys in brooklyn so
i'm more of a lawyer guy than a fan what
about you man
i would say lakers you know i'm a
california guy got a chance to you know
run with them with you know with kobe
and
we didn't get it done so i would love to
try to run the back with lebron in them
and try to get a ring as a laker
who's the better player between you two
right now me by far
by far yes by far i don't play
basketball
played and i don't know how long four
years yeah i don't play basketball i'm
the all-time leading scorer on the big
three
i got i got i got him a trophy for that
too
where where is that trophy from the big
three i i
i threw it in the garbage
uh good luck with the show and uh great
to talk to you guys
you know you know i'm i'm glad that you
found something that
you know is missing and that is
absolutely an opportunity for somebody
to walk in there and it's almost like a
safe space that
walking in and you guys identify you
understand and uh when you ask a
question it's
like this year version of the barbershop
yeah absolutely
it's the smoke shop that's what we
wanted to create you know it wasn't so
much
you know a stick of microphone in your
face interview situation we wanted to
create
you know kind of like a man cave
situation where there's no cameras if
there was no cameras you know how how
would a conversation go and that's what
we
tried to create and we've been able to
do that so we appreciate that and we
definitely need you on the show when you
get some time yes sir
do i what kind of questions are we
getting though
we're going to get all kinds of
questions you just got to make sure you
eat a couple edibles before you come and
you
you you you were one of the first guys
to interview us
well not only that but you set the
blueprint of how to build your own
and step away from the norm and stand on
your own so
you're a blueprint to us so we
appreciate being on your show and we got
to have you on our show so you can give
us some gain
i i would love to i never was high on
sportscenter okay
not as far as you know not as far as you
know
i may have acted like that but i was
none uh
matt stephen thank you and good luck
guys thank you thank you
thank you so much dan
a lot of fun matt barnes steven jackson
in-depth interviews with top players
luminaries covering topics from
basketball to social justice politics
music and more episodes available
in video and audio formats on the
showtime basketball youtube channel